good morning believe nation today's
messages have the courage to fail over
to you Hans Zimmer
we go after finishing my adventures of
dark night I decided we need to go and
two completely different direction
[Music]
while I think of the notes for the tune
I try to think of what's the sonic world
for going to pour this cue in it and
that's what we're doing we're
experimenting
that's what you're supposed to do you're
not supposed to stand still you don't
really want to be observed at your
greatest failures and you have to invite
failure if you want to go an experiment
and if you have to try to do something
original we have to have a certain
amount of privacy to have the courage to
fail feeling sucks okay nobody likes to
fail feeling like you lost feeling like
a loser feeling like you're not adding
value feeling like people don't
appreciate your work feeling like the
thing that you go and you do everyday
it's not having an impact it's not
yielding results that sucks that's a
terrible feeling I know because I failed
a lot and what you'll find is that most
successful people are also the ones who
failed a lot because what's the
alternative if you are not failing then
you're playing your life so safe that
you're not doing anything you're not
trying you have to fail feels a part of
experimentation it's only really a
failure if you don't learn from it you
don't grow you don't develop you don't
make it better
and I think the thing for me that's
really helped is I try not to make my
failures be massive failures I like to
test things on a small scale first a lot
of people they start a business and they
go all in and they'll mortgage their
house it'll take out a huge loan or get
an investment from their families and
just dig this huge hole for themselves
that this has to work out and then if it
doesn't then you're you played the rest
of your life so safe because you made
this one big mistake and I think that's
the biggest mistake of all because now
your life sucks because now you're never
going to take another chance because
that's the pattern that you've
established for yourself and so
understanding that failure is a part of
the path to success and making your
failures as small as possible you guys
are watching his youtube channel when I
started this channel this whole thing
was a hole it was just a little tiny
experiment right this end special series
was an experiment it started off as one
video as a test
okay I like that it was fun you know
people enjoyed it too great I'll make
another one okay I'll make another one
you know what this is I'm feeling it I
like this I like doing this every week
okay let's make it a series great daily
series love it the top ten was once a
week once a week on the weekend on a
Saturday okay it's going well people are
moved by it it's having an impact I like
doing the research I want to surround
myself with more of this knowledge okay
let's do twice a week
great that's working out okay let's move
to five times a week Monday to Friday
and now it's a it's a staple of my
channel what it's all about and I've had
tons of things that didn't work out lots
of series that I've canceled that you
guys probably even don't remember or
know of but you can go back on the
channel we've canceled more series than
we have currently running on the channel
through different experiments and
through failing and seem that doesn't
work okay great what was wrong about
that we're constantly running new tests
this week we're launching another series
the No Limit series let's see how it
does maybe it has an impact maybe not
maybe we keep running it maybe we blow
it up and do something else
failure is not this final point if you
failed before don't let that hold you
back and keep going because that's the
only real failure the only real failure
the only real failure is having this
idea having this vision for yourself
that what you want to go and accomplish
having this potential and leaving it
untapped continuing to play your life
small because you're too afraid to go
out and do something about it that's the
only real failure so the question today
for me is I want to know from you guys
what are you so afraid of
and that spiders and rollercoasters you
know like what's your biggest what's
your biggest fear that's holding you
back in your life I'm curious leave in
the comments below I'm gonna join the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot events VESA
so give me go